allez on continue ce 7,8 du lundi on va
parler poésie maintenant avec nos
invités catherine barbier bonsoir vous
êtes enseignante à l'école paulin
guyancourt pascal petit bonsoir vous
êtes poète ça qu'on peut vous présenter
mes jacques fournier on ne présente plus
et forment une file c'est notre invité
jacques fournier le directeur de la
maison de la poésie
l'enseigné commencer par vous c'est
parce que cet après-midi vos élèves de
cm2 ont restitué des textes autour des
écrits de martin luther king i have a
dream à l'occasion du 50e anniversaire
du son de son discours alors pourquoi
cette restitution pourquoi ce texte est
très fort pour des élèves de cm2 à
m'expliquer comment on travaille déjà
les mécènes de sursis alors t'aime très
fort non parce que je crois qu'elle va
les enfants on peut aborder justement on
doit aborder les thèmes importants que
effectivement quand j'ai bâti le projet
de classe culturelle avec catherine
baron l'année dernière elle a évoqué le
cinquantenaire doit y avait du rythme et
nous sommes une école où on a une
préoccupation en fait d'éducation
citoyenne parce que nous intégrons par
exemple des enfants sourds donc on a
déjà une approche du handicap et pour
nos enfants de la différence voilà ça
paraît quelque chose de normal et donc
l'année dernière on avait travaillé sur
la discrimination n'avait fait aussi un
livret
les ateliers d'écriture poétique autour
la discrimination donc cette année on a
pris le thème effectivement de la lutte
de
martin luther king pour la liberté et
l'égalité des droits
mais c'est avant d'arriver à ces thèmes
qui sont très importants c'est d'abord
j'allais dire par la découverte des mots
et puis donc avec pascal petit qui les a
fait jouer autour des mots que petit à
petit on a fait un trajet une réflexion
sur la liberté et l'égalité
oui parce qu'elle vous êtes 24 fois à
l'école quatre fois comment vous avez
travaillé avec eux et comment on
travaille des enfants de cm2 qui ont
entre 10 et 11 ans sont de toutes façons
d'abord on travaille avec l'enseignante
puisqu'on met au point les séances pas à
pas et puis et puis moi j'ai l'habitude
de travailler avec des enfants et même
avec des plus jeunes encore donc ça se
fait assez naturellement créé des
situations de l'écriture simple et puis
après il ya une prise de de jeu par les
enfants et c'est comme ça que ça
s'enclenche naturellement vite des
situations d'écriture simple où il adore
parce que là dans le texte alors oui
enfin je voudrais présenter
effectivement il ya des il ya des
poésies à partir du même de la même
lettre
alors là par exemple s'appelait en fait
on leur a fait découvrir un poète
surréaliste il s'appelle mes fans ce qui
a écrit en alphabet sourd aveugle et qui
est basée justement sur sept ce système
là c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois on va à
la ligne pour retrouver la même lettre
donc tous les verts commencent par la
même lettre parce que d'habitude on a
tendance à travailler avec la fin des
verts donc là j'ai pris parti de
travailler avec le début des verts est
en fait c'est une contrainte qui est
assez simple et qui est très stimulante
pour les enfants étaient très ludique en
fuite
c'est le côté très ludique et donc on
fait aimer la poésie avec le jeu oui oui
oui oui oui un dictionnaire nous aurons
comme son maître soit thématique c'est
pas et thématiques
un simple souvenir sur ont fait aimer la
poésie c'est aussi leur dire de la
poésie tous les jours c'est à dire que
avant que pascal interviennent dans ma
classe depuis le 3 septembre il y avait
je leur disais de la poésie tous les
jours et donc c'est un rituel
ce pays c'est un rituel c'est le matin
où harry voilà c'est
commence par sa voix la haye après midi
avait presque oublié la poésie du jour
et il m a pris la réclame et petit à
petit smet
parce que là la poésie qui induit des
contraintes et en même temps aussi très
libératrice par rapport aux émotions et
aux sensations et c'est ce qui n'est pas
assez travaillé à l'école justement
l'émotion à la sensation et quand on les
met en écriture poétique
on travaille sur l'émotion et sur la
sensation vous arrivez à trouver des
poètes différents âges et une
bibliothèque énorme
qu'est ce qui vous plaît vous dans la
poésie savoir si cette liberté ou 16 9
le travail sur l'émotion je pense sur
sur le côté absolument gratuit on dit
quelque chose et puis ça ça fait son
chemin ça a des résonances si le 50e
anniversaire de martin luther king
jaurès pour enchaîner sur ma question il
s'était finalement pas été une
thématique compliqué pour eux de
s'approprier un texte comme ça pour
prévenir une histoire l'eau
non là ils sont les enfants sont très
sensibles de toute façon à la justice à
l'injustice à ce qui est la règle n'est
pas la règle quand ils ne respectent pas
la règle savent très bien quand ils ne
respectent pas la règle est
effectivement aussi à l'égalité et ils
sont très ils sont très demandeurs
justement que nous les adultes on reste
on respecte
c'est ces thèmes là et donc non je
trouve pas que ce soit particulièrement
difficile à moi je travaille avec des
élèves de cm2 que je prépare quand le
collège
donc on est aussi à l'âge de 10-11 ans
dans une capacité de réflexion justement
sur sur ce qu'on attend de l'avenir est
sûre et se sont aussi en fait des futurs
adultes des enfants parents voient déjà
des traits de caractère chez eux qui
arrivent qui sont des traits caractère à
du ltte et donc on les aide quelque part
à se construire dans leurs têtes quand
on aborde ce genre de mort parce que
tout je vous propose enfin une petite
pause on va regarder un extrait parce
que la restitution freddy avait lieu cet
après midi à la maison de la poésie à
guyancourt on va regarder un extrait
vous allez certainement reconnaître ce
poème
sur mes cahiers d'écoliers sur mon
pupitre et réserves sur le sable sur la
neige écrite et surtout de les bras jure
sur toutes les pages blanches qui est
saint vallier au centre j'écris ton nom
sur cette image donnée de vous alarmer
des guerriers sur la couronne des rois
du monde sur les merveilles des minis
sur le talent des journées sur dix
saisons fiancée jetteront sur sont
surtout les chiffons de l'azur
survivants se sont assis sur le lac
j'écris ton nom la liberté de deux poids
deux joueurs vous aurez certainement
reconnu lanka restitution j'apprends et
je me tourne bien ou c'est vraiment le
moment fort et la suite alors la suite
ce sera pour nous asseoir à une chute
il a beau livre est d'ailleurs il ya ce
livret qui a été réalisé par résolument
une embardée qui a mis en page d'où ces
textes d'enfants et leurs dessins ça
n'est qu'une étape pour nous il s'agit
qu'une classe parmi tant d'autres qui
ont travaillé sur cette thématique cette
année parce qu'on va évoquer les 50 ans
du discours de martin luther king qui a
été prononcée le 28 août 1963
donc le 28 août 2013 50 ans jour pour
jour nous allons nous lancer un son à la
façade sur la façade de la maison de la
poésie dans l'après midi grâce à sylvie
gastaud qui par ailleurs va lancer une
exposition sonore qui donnera à entendre
tout ce que cette dentellières du son a
pu collecter comme sont à travers tout
le département des yvelines pour évoquer
un livre dreams dans des classes auprès
des gens elle a demandé à des dizaines
et des dizaines de personnes de dire ce
texte dans leur langue en vietnamien en
italien en espagnol en brésilien en
français voilà et elle va faire un
mélange de tout ça et va construire une
vraie exposition sonore on pourra
entendre des sons pendant deux mois la
maison de la poésie et ce travail qui a
été mené grâce à
l'implication de catherine baron ma
collaboratrice qui a tout de suite des
quêtes dès qu'on a proposé ce thème en
dernier déguisements monter ce projet
l'an dernier il ya un an exactement
elle m'a dit ça on va travailler dessus
toute l'année avec des classes donc
beaucoup de classes ont travaillé sur
cette thématique là parce que c'est pas
tant le discours qui est intéressant que
tout ce qu'il contient tout ce qu'il
peut être appliquée fait réécrire un
enfant du cir comprendre que il a le
droit d'écrire tout autant que l'autre
c'est ça fait partie du discours de
martin luther king des choses qu'ils
allaient finir par exemple j'ai finir
là-dessus
joes qu'ils ont pu dire tout à l'heure
quand catherine a terminé la restitution
avec eux y en a un qui a dit on a appris
la liberté d'écrire et ça c'est fabuleux
c'est à dire qu'il se dise ont
complètement écouter l'autre aussi on
l'a bien vu là dans cette restitution de
liberté de paul eluard écouter l'autre
quand il dit quand il dit le poème le
regarder c'est ça aussi les droits
civiques les écouter partager des
émotions partagées restitution à du 28
août au 19 19 heures à la maison de la
poésie merci à vous trois ans mercy est
venu sur le plateau du 7-8